bonjour mon invité aujourd'hui c'est
marc fesneau vous êtes le secrétaire
général du modem le mouvement démocrate
de françois bayrou donc de passage sur
la presqu'île guérandaise marc fesneau
le numéro deux du modem alors le modèle
vous présenter quelques candidats pas
dans toutes les circonscriptions entre
sur la loire atlantique sur tout le
littoral de loire-atlantique et des
circonscriptions vous êtes présent de
tous vous n'êtes pas présent comment les
choses se sont organisés écoutez les
choses se sont organisées de la façon
suivante on avait envie d'être présent
dans ces élections départementales pour
tout vous dire on était plutôt près
d'ailleurs à travailler avec l'ump l'ump
a fait malheureusement choix plus tout
se replier sur elle même
c'est d'ailleurs on voit bien que c'est
le débat qui traverse l'ump au niveau
national et donc du coup on n'était pas
non plus dans le stakhanovisme des
candidatures pour poser des candidatures
et donc on a voulu faire dans des
endroits où nous avions une implantation
historique et où nous avions des
candidats que nous pensions pouvoir
présenter aux suffrages donc à guérande
donc à nantes et donc à saint nazaire
c'est dans ses trois pôles là qu'on a
décidé de présenter des candidatures
avec des candidatures parfois uniquement
avec des candidats du mouvement
démocrate
parfois que des gens qui viennent
d'autres horizons en particulier par
exemple d'ailleurs comme catherine
bailhache qui est plutôt l'horizon de
l'ump
l'idée étant de montrer que sur un sujet
comme le sujet départementale il y aura
d'autres échéances nationales pour qu'on
va pas y venir là mais il ya capacité
que des gens qui sont pas forcément dans
les mêmes parties qui passe par dessus
les les frontières partisanes ou
partisane pardon décide de se rassembler
c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire
effectivement dans ce canton de guérande
donc on va dire à saint nazaire et à
dominique trigodet jean michel texier
le candidat du modem et sur le canton 2
grande catherine bailhache et xavier
bruckert financé par total
connaît bien que j'imagine donc c'est
les deux seuls candidats non mais vous
avez anne-marie bouter et thierry
maillard sur nantes voilà
ok très bien de mémoire vous en avez
dans le morbihan aussi nous en avons
dans le morbihan alors nous en avons je
veux pas de vous dire de bêtises nous en
avons à lorient oui et nous en avons
dans un autre canton mais je vais vous
dire une bêtise ciboure balises mais les
auditeurs qui nous écoutent d'environ
les candidats nous en avons dans trois
cantons dans le morbihan alors où en
êtes vous actuellement au modem dire
quelque chose de très important a voulu
s'allier avec l'ump ça ça ne s'est pas
fait est ce que ça signifie vraiment que
le modem a acquitté sa bulle leur
politique qu'elle occupait dans le
système jusqu'à présent pas si c'est une
bulle hors politique d'abord je crois qu
hors clivage voilà enrc l'image sage
qu'on alors là c'est triste on lâche des
ponts dont nous n'avons pas quitté
l'idée qu'à un moment il faudra dépasser
les clivages et d'ailleurs les
traditionnellement votre famille c'est
l'udf historiquement historiquement
notre famille c'est l'udf d'ailleurs
j'en viens puisque j'étais une première
engagement politique était à l'udf en
même temps quand on voit la situation au
niveau local au niveau national il ya
quand même besoin de parts de sortir de
la frontière ou de la ligne comme il
disait tout à l'heure où on place les
gens adro à droite ou à gauche d'un
échiquier et celui un certain nombre de
sujets on parle de la loi macron eloi
macroéconomique lefebvre était à votre
place et quelques jours il a voté la loi
mac mais voyez bien qu'il ya des gens
comme frédéric lefebvre 10 mais attendez
c'est pas parce que c'est une nouvelle
couche télé mauvaise de même que c'est
pas parce que c'est une loi droite que
la gauche est obligé comme le chien de
pavlov de voter contre mais c'est la
france qui est comme ça mais vous croyez
pas que ça a mis la france dans le mur
vous savez j'ai le sentiment que ça a
mis aujourd'hui est-ce que la france
depuis qu'elle est complètement dans
cette logique bipartisane ce qui n'était
pas le cas du temps du général de gaulle
c'était sans doute pas le cas des
présidents des présidents qui l'ont un
peu qu'ils m'ont succédé après mais là
on est vraiment dans une logique tout à
fait bipolariser en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on a essayé nous expliquer que bmp au
ps
aujourd'hui on est dans un schéma
nouveau d'ailleurs parce qu'on est dans
un schéma tri polarisé finalement et
puis ça c'est autre chose mais vous êtes
vous avez au modem président en
l'occurrence françois bayrou qui est
suffisamment les très cultivée en
matière d'histoire qu'on a fait savoir
que ce clivage remonte à la révolution
française finalement et de primes depuis
1789 on est resté on est resté sur le
droit de gauche historiquement on est
resté comme ça c'est comme ça que s'est
construit et bien que la droite actuelle
soit pas la droite de la révolution
française
c'était pour soutenir l'euro oui
absolument pas tout à fait la même chose
des catholiques et royaliste mais je
pense que on est dans un moment j'ai pas
dit que c'était un il faut en permanence
qu'on passe par dessus les clivages mais
dans un moment de crise comme celui
qu'on connaît moi je connais pas de pays
qui à un moment où on ne se relève pas
de la situation de crise alors là c'est
une crise qui n'est pas celle comme
celle de 45 en sortie de guerre
je ne tenais pas un pays qui ne sortent
pas de la crise un moment par l'idée
qu'il faut dépasser les clivages sans
renoncer à ce qu'on ait les uns et les
autres il ya des gens qui sont à droite
il ya des gens qui sont à gauche que des
gens qui sont plutôt modérée au centre
de la vie politique
même si historiquement effectivement
c'était plutôt centre-droit mais que ces
gens là un moment dans une période de
temps donnée et envie de se parler
après tout les escapades et réforme cinq
ou six réformes sur lesquelles on peut
être d'accord
pourquoi pas c'est un peu ce que dit
alain juppé pour tout vous dire oui
c'est un peu le chemin que fait-on des
gens comme frédéric le faire en dix ans
attendait est ce que la loi les bonnes
ou les mauvaises la question celle là ce
qu'elle sait pas si l'aide droite ou de
gauche qu'on s'en fiche alors je pense
que les choses évolueront jeu parce que
vous en pensez avec les nouvelles
générations et les générations connu
alors vous vous a vu ce que vous êtes
ses militants à l'udf avant vous aviez
connu le clivage du mur de berlin qui
était le clivage finalement entre les
bons et les méchants et ce clivage est
resté chez beaucoup de générations qui
sont issus de sa génération mais
maintenant quand on discute avec des
jeunes d'une trentaine d'années
l'histoire gauche droite est ouest pour
eux ça leur échappe totalement
alors il s'est peut-être là que ça va
changer on est complètement d'accord
mais là vous êtes dans une version
optimiste le risque aussi c'est que ça
leur est actuellement si ça les
intéresse plus on voit que la moitié des
jeunes veulent voter front national vous
avez vu ça j'ai vu ça va moi que la
moitié
je je je sais pas ce qui relèvera je
pense qu'ils sont plus dans ce qui va
effectivement pour des raisons
historiques le temps passait ses étés
les repères liée à une histoire vécue
disparaissent parce que le temps fait
son oeuvre
ce dont je ne voudrais pas c'est qu' ils
soient au point d'être sans repère alors
je parle comme si j'étais déjà d'une
génération qui dirigeait jusque quand
même pas tout à fait un jean tour 10e
poser des questions qui étaient aussi je
suis pas sûr que j'ai peur aussi qu'ils
soient combos à ce point dégoûté de la
vie politique il ay soit dans
l'abstention et le l'abstention durable
à l'abstention ponctuelle ou vers les
votes extrêmes sont d'ailleurs plutôt
avec l' envie de renverser la table et
de reverser l'ensemble du je pense que
les gens qui sont sur ce vote là
aujourd'hui pour la plupart d'entre eux
ils sont sur un vote de caisse qui
renverse la table aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui en huit systèmes et ce qui va les
emmerder le plus vous pour parler
crûment c'est ça c'est exactement ça et
donc ils disent pas ce qui les ennuie le
plus c'est que le soir
voilà et moi je ça les ennuie en même
temps sa liste dans l'ue pas parce que
ça permet de rester un épouvantail qui
commodément permet de continuer comme
avant
finalement avec que leur dites-vous
finalement à toutes ces générations à
tous ces gens je parle est rude avec le
faire qu'ils étaient à votre place il ya
quelques jours il était à la baule parce
qu'il est comme une maison pas très loin
puis en quittant le studio on va chez le
buraliste fait lever le buraliste lui
dit
le couple arrive tout de suite rue mais
toute façon on va voter front national
et pourquoi a dit parce que ça emmerde
la classe politique
mais le programme du front national il
n'est pas bon pour me la france
la réponse était on le sait mais ça vous
emmerde cdu michel audiard qu on est
dans un mur
oui mais c'est exactement ce que vous
décrivez en même temps qu on vote on
prend une responsabilité quand vous
votez on dit il c'est pas un vote
d'adhésion et au moins un vote
d'adhésion l'idée pendant envie de
renverser les choses maintenant il va y
avoir des
là si on continue comme ça y'a déjà il y
aura des isolés chez nous on va chez
cipal ici on aura des élus
ça veut dire qu'il serait en capacité
j'étais dans le vaucluse il ya deux
jours ils seront en capacité dans le
vaucluse de gouverner vaucluse bien sûr
est ce que c'est ce que les gens veulent
dire qu'à un moment le vote
il porte une responsabilité quand il est
si massif et donc notre mêlée jouve mais
je ne cherche pas le monde elle a tout
essayé vous avez échoué mais c'est vrai
quand on entend les gens comme françois
mitterrand sous la fameuse foire où je
suis plutôt contre le chômage on a tout
essayé essayé contre le chômage est bas
puisque vous avez tout essayé merci à
eux et en même temps comme vous dites
ils disent on va essayer en même temps
existe mais de toute façon c'est bien
quand les essayant ça marchera pas et de
ce point de vue là je disais ça tout à
l'heure à la réunion quand vous regardez
ce qu'ils l'expérience grecque est
intéressante parce que finalement qu'est
ce qu'ils disent qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait les grecs ils ont voulu aussi
mettre en l'air un système le système de
papa andré ou et autres qui est d'une
génération sur l'autre se passait le
pouvoir se passer le sel restent et ils
ont mis saaba ils ont voté pour un
leader qui avait du charisme a
incontestablement qui globalement sur un
certain nombre de sujets dit la même
chose que marine le pen est cool l'enjeu
sur vous et et mélenchon mais bon un
mois plus tard il revient en arrière il
revient en arrière a repris la réalité
de la vie quand il ya des donateurs et
qu'il faut faire les paye à la fin et
alors donc il ya 2 10 à 2 possibilités
soit il était incompétent et inconscient
quand au point de penser que ce qu'ils
proposent est allé marcher je peux pas
croire ça soit il sait sciemment qu'il a
menti aux gens résidence de de la
gueule du monde entier et vous pensez
pas que ça aussi ça nourrit encore la
désespérance il ya un moment
moi je comprends la désespérance est ce
que vous décrivez sur la colère des gens
je le comprends absolument mais il ya un
moment mais c'est notre responsabilité
c'est toute cette désespérance je
n'exonère pas forcément d'ailleurs le
mouvement démocrate de sa part en dehors
comment parler de bulle tout à l'heure
simplement nous on pense que il ya un
besoin de rassemblements nouveaux qui
permettent de répondre à cette
désespérance d'abord de dire qu'il ya
des choses qui ne vont pas et de pas moi
quand j'entends le gouvernement tous les
matins dire on va sortir du tunnel je
pense qu'ils sont pas en contact avec la
réalité de ce que vivent les gens
moi je suis mère dans une petite commune
du loir et cher
quand vous leur dites là on est sur le
chemin de la croissance d'ailleurs les
si les signaux commence à passer à
l'orangé les genres ils ont envie de
voter pour renverser la table en disant
vous vous fichez de nous et c'est ça qui
est désespérant et donc nous la
conscience que nous avons le saas est de
dire oui il ya besoin de renverser la
table mais renverser la table sur un
schéma est un projet qui tient la route
parce que si c'est pour renverser la
table et qu'il se passe rien et que ce
soit encore pire après schéma grecque
ça sert à rien c'est inutile on repère
encore du temps et on veut sortir de
l'alternance droite gauche qui échouent
beau sortir 6 une nouvelle alternance
qui soit essayons ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure fort justement essayons
tient après tout le vote front c'est un
voix qui renverse la table et on sait
oui mais non parce qu'on sortira pas de
l'euro sauf si on te pas sortir l'euro
on peut pas sortir la pâques les
politiques d'immigration c'est tellement
simple de dire on va faire immigration
zéro
vous connaissez un peu un pays dans le
monde en dehors de la corée du nord qui
soit capable d'empêcher l'immigration
donc c'est pas ça la question à la
question c'est la régulation des flux et
la question c'est du développement dans
ces pays là est la question c'est
d'éviter qu'on se retrouve avec des
conflits comme le conflit syrien aux
libyens qui nous amène en italie et donc
chez nous parce que ça c'est la vérité
des flots de gens qui sont en train
d'essayer de sauver leur peau parce que
quand votre choix c'est soit mourir chez
vous ou prendre un bateau est allé en
france
vous comme moi ont fait le même choix
prend le bateau rend le bateau et dont
vous empêchez pas les bateaux d'arriver
sur les côtes parce qu'on va pas couler
les bateaux avec des gens qui essayent
de sauver leur vie parce qu'on est quand
même encore en régime démocratique
donc voyez ce que je veux dire c'est à
dire qu'il ya un besoin d'avoir un
discours à la fois solides sur wii ça va
pas et oui on est conscient que le
système est à la dérive
puisqu'on est on était sûrs lors
l'instant mais non les solutions propose
marine le pen ne va pas nous ne
résoudrons pas vos problèmes alors on va
s'attarder là dessus on va revenir sur
le modem que c'est avec marc fesneau
secrétaire général le numéro deux du
mouvement démocrate modem de françois
bayrou qui je le rappelle je présente
des candidats pour ces départementale
sur saint nazaire 2 avec trois minutes
avec dominique trigodet jean michel
texier pluie sur guérande avec catherine
bailhache et sur l'angle
au caire et puis sur nantes aussi avec
thierry malades et à marie douthe et
alma reboot et voilà est ce que le
moderne n'arrive pas trop tard avec des
solutions apaisé alors que le pays ne
s'aiment pas et les gens sont prêts à
les gens se détestent le jeu fait un
constat assez triste mais une partie de
la france des tests le parti ou un tiers
des tests l'autre tiers le mot cruel le
mot est fort mais on est dans un pays où
les clivages maintenant sont très
tendues et vous arrivez avec des
messages qui sont plutôt de
réconciliation avec des recettes
économiques qui sont traditionnellement
celle de la famille politique à laquelle
vous appartenez écoeurait bon bah avait
déjà été le premier à mettre sur la
table tout le monde ricaner à l'époque
et on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui il avait
raison avant tout le monde sur tous les
sujets on me dira d'ailleurs la même
chose de françois bayrou sur un certain
nombre de sujets mais là la
privatisation des autoroutes l'arbitrage
tapie la dette et le déficit qu'il a
toujours dilate aujourd'hui la mairie en
2002 sur la dette et les déficits il il
était à bord mais ce que vous arrivez
pas trop tarder avec un message et une
image pardonnez-moi si le mot n'est pas
très juste mais un peu hors gillick un
peu un peu gentil alors qu' on en est au
stade où les gens ont envie de sortir la
kalachnikov ou le couteau dans les
esprits oui oui non mais je comprends ce
que vous l'aidiez on est d'abord né dans
un pays en crise et comme tous les pays
en crise on cherche des boucs émissaires
et on est en tension les uns avec les
autres
ça je ne je ne dis pas que ce que vous
dites est faux ce qu'il faut pas nier la
réalité rien de pire dans le monde
politique aujourd'hui que des gens qui
nient la réalité donc je ne nie pas
cette cette tentation cette envie cette
réalité
deuxième chose si on est un responsable
politique du modem ou d'ailleurs la
responsabilité c'est pas mettre le pays
à feu et à sang
donc c'est pas une question d' angélisme
c'est une question de responsabilité je
veux moi je suis pas engagé en politique
pour voir des gens s'entretuent et
personne j'espère donc on est plutôt là
pour apporter des solutions qui soient
des solutions de réconciliation je pense
que les gens sont à la fois intentions
même si ça a été un parfait et même si
on en a fait un peu beaucoup parfois
mais le 11 janvier c'était aussi ça
c'est l envie d'être ensemble tout le
monde n'y était pas on sait très bien ce
qui a été dit sur cette grande
manifestation suite aux attentats du 7
mai je crois qu'il y avait une envie de
collectif on est dans une société la
société française comme toutes les
sociétés qui sont des sociétés de plus
en plus individualiste et c'est ça la
réalité du monde dans lequel on vit
malheureusement mais il ya quand même
toujours l'espoir parce que je crois que
c'est un espoir humain est il un espoir
l'humanité un moment de retrouver un
projet commun et je pense que les gens
sont à la fois attention à la fois avec
les pulsions cours nous pouvons tous
avoir un jeu m'exonère pas le dire j'ai
trouvé un coupable j'ai envie de taper
sur intel et en même temps l' envie de
dire que si on se dépasser un peu et
qu'on avait envie de faire collectif et
ça je suis pas sûre ce soir j'ai lic
je pense que c'est une élévation de soi
même voyez ce que je veux dire c'est pas
de l'angélisme
vous avez une lecture très intéressante
du 11 janvier à ce que vous décelé une
envie de collectif
certains pourraient y déceler une
agrégation d'individualisme de gens qui
étaient tous là pour des raisons
totalement différentes et dans les
slogans on le voyait bien je vais mieux
exprimer
ma question je vais pas donner de
pourcentage parce que j'ai aucune étude
faite aux doigts au doigt mouillé donc
je vais le dire n'importe comment
vous avez peut-être un tir de gens qui
étaient là lors en janvier contre
l'immigration j'ai bien vu sur une
chaîne de télévision l'a interrogé et
des micro trottoirs il ya eu des gens
qui étaient là pour dire pourquoi tu es
là on est là contre l'islam
bon ça vous aviez une tout cas pas
pareil que l'on contre l'immigration
mais aussi quand ils jouent contre
l'immigration est contestable et j'ai
entendu des mots voilà vous avez aussi à
notre à notre pourcentage de gens qui
étaient là justement pour le vivre
ensemble pour dire dans le padd à valga
totalement différent d'autres gens qui
étaient uniquement là pour la liberté
d'expression
d'autres gens qui étaient là avec des
valeurs plus soixante huitarde plus et
qui voyait un peu une victoire un peu de
l'esprit charlie ce que je veux dire
c'est une agrégation de gens très très
différents le mais je ne lis pas ce que
vous dites mais ces gens là où ils ont
envie de se retrouver ensemble dans la
rue parce qu'ils savaient qu'ils étaient
différents
il ya une envie quasi animale au bon
sens du terme de dans la peur collective
qui nous saisissent et l'effroi
collectif qui nous a saisi ces nous a
saisis du moment tant qu inattendue de
charlie et de la d'épicerie cacher et de
la haie du dénouement et et de voir ce
que disait ces gens là je crois qu'il y
avait une envie de simplement d'être
dans la rue ensemble
moi j'ai fait la manif de la manif hong
il faut pas dire manif personne n'aime
pas dire au niveau du rassemblement le
rassemblement moi je descends très
rarement dans la rue pour dire des
choses c'est même la première fois je
les sens vraiment dans la rue jamais été
à une manifestation de paysans mais j'ai
été à blois j'étais à paris après
j'étais j'ai filé sur paris j'ai dit je
veux voir et je veux sentir ça j'ai
senti j'ai d'abord les gens parlaient
pas car évidemment quand on vous tend un
micro vous parler mais j'ai trouvé que
les gens étaient tout en retenue moi
j'ai entendu liberté et j'ai entendu la
marseillaise comme jamais j'ai entendu
chanter la marseillaise sauf quand vous
allez vous comme les aimez vous comme
moi vous revoir un match de foot ou de
rugby ou d'autres choses j'ai entendu
chanter la marseillaise comme un espèce
de vague de marseillaise qui revenait
simplement pour dire tous ces gens
étaient différents mais tous ces gens il
portait quelque chose de collectif j'ai
pas dit qu'il n'avait pas des
motivations initiales qui étaient
différentes
mais il avait envie de se retrouver mais
ce n'est pas une affirmation c'est une
question peut-être le dos rond et
deuxièmement j'ai assuré j'ai trouvé
beaucoup de g passants qui de rejet de
quoi que ce soit j'ai senti leur rejet
de la violence de la haine mais de la
haine exprimée au travers de ces
islamistes là globalement le rejet de la
haine c'est j'ai trouvé des gens
pacifiques dans la rue dont ils sortent
les gens étaient d'ailleurs vous aviez
des gamarus de cinq ans au milieu d'une
foule immense à paris c'était est folle
et gonflé même en poussette
donc il y avait quelque chose de d'abord
on n'a pas la trouille de on est content
d'être ensemble comme le troupeau se
serrent face à des ennemis
moi j'ai senti ça comme un truc que je
me suis passé de ce qu'ils ont dit long
janvier plus rien ne sera comme avant
ça c'est une facilité de langage mais il
s'est passé dans la tête des gens
quelque chose mais il s'est aussi passé
quelque chose de cette c'est à dire que
le set les gens se sont saisis de
l'horreur de ces mouvements
fondamentalistes et de ce qui professait
de l'horreur sur notre propre territoire
ce que voir des gens heureusement les
voit pas trop égorgé sur youtube
c'est une chose mais voir des gens sur
votre propre territoire qui procède de
la même façon c'est une autre affaire
parce que tant que si en syrie et on
peut comprendre pourquoi les syriens
après ils prennent les bateaux et fiche
le camp parce qu'ils sont pas passés à
ces fondamentalistes ou parce qu'ils
sont pas de la religion qu'il faut dans
ce pays là et pour revenir à la question
tout à l'heure sur l'immigration donc
j'ai senti ça mais ça veut pas dire que
ça fait une transformation ça veut dire
j'ai senti aussi d'ailleurs je vous le
dis au passage qu' il n'avait pas envie
de l'autorité publique c'est à dire que
l'idée de défiler avec son écharpe
moi j'ai défilé sens des chars parce que
je considère pas que j'ai pas vu
d'hommes politiques venir que j'ai
conservé la vallée y aller comme un
citoyen parce que je pense que je suis
maire et que j'ai le droit a coûté une
jambe bleu blanc rouge du jeu tu vaut
pas plus que celui qui dans la rue à
côté de moi
et plus de devoir d'une certaine façon
j'ai des droits comme merde parce que
c'est la loi qui nous confère mais
pourquoi il me différencier les autres
cette les pièces de la france qui était
dans la rue
en tout cas une partie de la france une
partie ce que vous l'exprimez j'ai
trouvé ça dit marc fesneau du mouvement
démocrate
alors on va revenir sur l'économie parce
qu'en fait il ya vraiment un sujet sur
lequel le modem a été empreinte c'est la
dépense publique la nécessité de nous
alerter pas casser tech sont présents
chez elle et aussi à l'air et demi avant
dès 2002 avec un françois b on n'a pas
été écouté finalement ce sera pareil
avec raymond barre en 1988 il n'a pas
été écouté non plus comment expliquer et
là on a le sentiment on est encore en
train de remettre de la poussière sous
le tapis et qu'en 2017
ça va être pareil oui j'ai le sentiment
que oui mais comment on fait rentrer à
bord il ya une forme je parle pas des
français là je parle des gouvernants est
une forme d'arrogance française c'est de
croire qu'on est toujours plus malin que
les autres c'est à dire qu'on est plus
malin que les allemands on est plus
malin que les anglais on est plus malin
les plus organisés que les espagnols et
les italiens enfin on a des liens aussi
on se regarde la surnomme parfois les
autres un jour j'ai interviewé christian
saint-etienne et c'est bien ce qui était
aussi que proche mais absolument proches
du modem un volant ou les dix exactement
ça ce qui va arriver à à la grèce ça
risque d'arriver à la france et puis moi
j'ai déjà autres motards peu la preuve
non monsieur guy n'importe quoi on les
la france quand même ça veut dire que
vous voyez ces vauriens degré et pousser
pour portugais évidemment mais pas nous
quand même quelque chose d'un peu
d'arrogance des gouvernants deuxième
chose on est un pays qui culturellement
vit et pense par la dépense publique en
particulier celle de l'étang pourrait
parler de celles des collectivités parce
que là ça fait un peu taper dur et qui
pensent que la solution c'est quand même
toujours la dépense publique quelle que
soit d'ailleurs les gouvernements puis
certaine façon l'arrière des mesures un
aux lots quai général-de-gaulle
ils étaient emparés de croissance forte
moi j'aime beaucoup la même chose mais
cet esprit étatiste a soufflé sur la
france est elle hors la loi juste un peu
baissé sous georges pompidou et nerveux
nous les citoyens et nous les hommes
politiques on a aussi une responsabilité
collective c'est que dès qu'il ya un
problème on dit mais qu'est ce que fait
l'état
qu'est ce qui va donner comment il va
régler le chômage moi je voyais l'autre
jour je sais plus loin un tract je
consultais les socialistes mais ça
aurait pu l'être d'autant disant ben on
est content au travers d'un conseiller
départemental on va créer des emplois
des emplois publics c'est des emplois de
la dette
aujourd'hui le jour où on en crée des
emplois publics à l'équilibré
ça me va bien mais des emplois publics
supplémentaires aujourd'hui c'est de la
tête qu'on creuse de notre espèce de
conscience collective et puis quelque
chose vis-à-vis de nos partenaires
européens et vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes
c'est on doit passer en dessous de 3 en
2008 arrive la crise donc nicolas
sarkozy négocié comme tout le monde
d'ailleurs pour le court on passe à six
ou sept pour cent de déficit
il produit intérieur but brut et après
on se donne des objectifs qui ont dû
battre en 2012 clair précis en 2013 puis
après c'est en 2014 puis après c'est en
quand vous dites de donner des objectifs
de réduction de la dette et que vous ne
l'étiez jamais il ya plus de crédit de
la parole politique alors comment vous
devrez vous voulez vous que les citoyens
nous croient et là encore on vient
d'aller
imploré bruxelles s'il vous plaît
monsieur le bourreau encore un peu mais
un peu mais c'est le bourg mais ce
cadbury ça pourrait être aussi il dit
oui mais il dit il dit oui pourquoi
parce qu'on a une chance
d'une certaine façon et c'est là qu'on
l'a peut-être des raisons d'être de
parfois de gonfler les bras c'est que
l'on n'est la une des deux plus grandes
puissances économiques de la zone euro
et donc si nous nous effondrons alors là
on embarque le système est donc bonjour
toujours acheter versailles
disons qu'ils on a une vue sur un
certain nombre de biens publics prendre
commencé avant qu'ils achètent en bas on
se battra comme en mai
mais il en restait là aux portes de
toulouse moi je suis d'ailleurs je fais
une petite digression là dessus moi je
suis plutôt de pensée libérale au bon
sens du terme d'un point de vue
économique je pense que les chefs
d'entreprise et que la puissance
étatique elle doit intervenir de temps
en temps quand il ya des faux le privé
ou que le privé ce que mal des choses
mais qu'après il faut sentir et enfin
vendre l'aéroport de toulouse en
majorité à des chinois
il faut quand même avoir des drôles
d'idées commencer le centre névralgique
représente toulouse à deux pas des rebus
je tousse c'est une drôle d'idée
franchement pour mettre des appareils
photos c'est bien je suis pas sûr que
tout peut cependant de 30% et je
rappelle en plus sur l'aéroport quand
même utilisé le film digressions un peu
loin de de la baule mais il y avait une
autre femme et se stratégie vous avez
une offre française
c'était aéroports de paris faudrait pas
qu'on aurait pu confier aéroports de
paris boîte française est privé la
gestion de l'aéroport de toulouse ces
espèces de passion pour les qatariens de
passion pour les chinois
je perds passionné je jeu ce point de
vue là je considère qu'il ya quand même
des enjeux stratégiques et quand vous
regardez les grands pays les chinois les
américains et les allemands par exemple
peut il défendre leurs intérêts
nationaux il ya quand même des choses
vitales qui ne vendent pas oui c'est un
peu le pas le commerce à une business
oui ce que je dire enfin alors marc
marquez dont on a parlé d'économie
évidemment je suis un des axes forts du
monde mais si ça va mal en france toute
façon quand on sait que consommer ou pas
on plaide pour l'instruction pour
l'histoire il se place
les français ne connaissent plus la leur
leurs histoires on pourrait faire la
même remarque sur la culture économique
qui est catastrophique
c'est ce qui fait que les gens ne
raisonne pas en pensant que l'argent est
à un circuit à des entrepreneurs là les
gens pensent que comme les enfants de 5
ans avec leurs parents quand ils tirent
à la carte bleue ils ont l'impression
que l'argent sans bouillir
c'est un peu pareil faune culturel mais
là je ne sais pas grief aux citoyens
uniquement les griefs aussi aux hommes
politiques quand vous avez des gens
comme arnaud montebourg qu'avec les
attitudes qu'ils ont eu vis-à-vis du
monde économique
oc c'est dramatique il a peut-être temps
maintenant qu'il est à l'école et à
l'école aux états unis enfin je sais pas
si tu donnes déco oscillant prend là bas
mais il ya quand même quelque chose de
quelqu'un qui dit je vais empêcher je
vais moi avec ses petits bras il n'a pas
un rond dans les poches
arnaud montebourg quand ils disent non
l'état n'a plus la puissance d'armes
achetées pourrait qu'on privatise autre
chose il fait croire des choses fausses
et à dire qu'il fait croire que c'est
l'état qui organise l'économie en france
et quand il dit j'ai sauvé telle
entreprise et que vous regardez un an
après ça va faire bientôt un an qu'il
est parti les entreprises qu'il a
théoriquement sauvé qui ont disparu
c'est une escroquerie intellectuelle
c'est une déception pour les citoyens
après faut pas s'étonner qu'ils aillent
voter extrême et c'est une acculturation
qu'on ne continue à faire percolé dans
la la population sur le thème
en fait l'économie et c'est pas quelque
chose comme vous croyez c'est l'état qui
décide quoi c'est l'état qui peut la
puissance fesses de truc marche pas
alors que l'état soit stratège et qui
décide par exemple comme il l'a fait sur
une terre de développer des grandes
filières es filière énergétique et
filière automobile quand il a fallu rond
ça ça me paraît normal
moi je pense je crois pas à la main
invisible je crois pas que le marché se
régule tout seul je crois pas qu un
moment il y ait de l'état et pas besoin
de dire stop ça c'est pas l'intérêt
général et ça c'est pas un intérêt
public
mais penser qu'on doit se mêler tous
occupés tous et que tout ça se fait
d'abord avec les qu'avec les capacités
financières qu'on annoncera peut pas se
faire et 2 ça donne le sentiment
vraiment que le monde économique et où
la dépense de l'état dans le monde
économique y vit en partie sans nous
mais c'est pas forcément dramatique
simplement on est là pour le réguler
nous vous donner une image à travers vos
propos qui sont passionnants marc
raynaud
du modem qui revient sous un aspect evs
ne le prenez pas comme caricatures sont
tous ma part j'en aspect peut-être une
approche économique plus libéral et il
s'avère que cette approche économique la
plus libérale n'est absolument pas
représentés dans le paysage politique
français
quand vous voyez sur le plan économique
marine le pen le front national qui est
un peu sur des thèses économiques
maintenant qu'ils sont proches ces
méchants communistes voilages et les
deux mêlant chant le ps on connaît de
l'ump quand même assez étatiste et
classique n'a pas changé et mangent dans
vos propos je ne décèle pas où je ne
décelait pas mais je pense que les
auditeurs aussi du coup ne décelait pas
cette orientation peut-être plus libéral
de la médecine libérale or le mot
libéral en france a mauvaise presse
malheureusement mal je le vois c'est la
liberté ah oui pour moi c'est notre
hôtel et de liberté gaci le libéral
c'est la capacité donnée aux chefs des
chefs d'entreprises de se développer
dans ce que je veux dire je ne disais
pas mettre les pauvres au coin de la rue
et l'exode dr en soit si le libéral
c'est fait c'est de dire il faut qu'on
lève un certain nombre de normes qui
empêche les entreprises les
collectivités je suis maire et président
de commune au mipcom et je vois très
bien de quoi on parle de simplement
développer des projets alors là ce
moment là je l'assumé
en france quand vous dites libérales
c'est effectivement ce que je désire
c'est à dire une équité du système les
plus faibles sont les plus écrasé non je
pense qu'on peut à la fois prôné la
liberté d'entreprendre la liberté de
l'est quand je dis entreprendre c'est
pas que les entreprises
c'est dans une association quand vous
portez un projet c'est dans une
collection vous voulez monter n'importe
quel projet que vous voulez c'est la
liberté d'entreprendre mais vous êtes le
premier vote l'un des premiers jusqu'à
présent l'offre politique
je sais d'alain madelin mais oui mais
c'est déjà l'été libertariens aussi il a
perdu beaucoup de gens parce qu'elle
était libertarien il était libérable
d'un pointu source de la société
libertarien aussi libertarian signifie
l'europe l'été pour la légalisation de
la drogue cannabis pour être pour être
précis au cas présent j'ai pas entendu
franchement route pour las des menaces
non ça pour le coup non la plus
traditionnelle n'est plus traditionnelle
ça mériterait un débat mais je crois
qu'il faut pas ouvrir ce débat je pense
d'ailleurs que le pays n'a pas besoin de
débats sociétaux de débat de cette
nature là c'est pas le moment c'est pas
le moment moi je suis j'ai une
imposition arrêté qui est peut-être je
vois pas l'intérêt de ce genre de choses
là pour le coup l'une concerne très
libérale derrière il n'y a pas que la
question de la santé publique et les
questions qu'on peut rattraper de la
fiscalité derrière parce que les états
unis qui vient de l'est de la protection
sociale
mais moi je pense que le pays n'a pas
besoin de débats sociétaux
je trouvais d'ailleurs que de ce point
de vue là le la sphère du mariage pour
tous avait été très mal conduite parce
que ça a été un moment de d'extrême
tension entre des gens et on a mis des
gens dans des espèces deux camps chacun
est enfermé dans son camp d'ailleurs que
je trouve que c'est un moment assez
malsain de se diviser
oui et puis se comprenaient on a fait
émerger chez les uns et les autres ce
qui a de plus parce que c'est toujours
les extrêmes dans ces cas là les plus
extrémistes de chaque camp a fait on a
fait émerger ce qu'il ya de plus
désagréable dans un débat public c'est à
dire la caricature et le l'anathème sur
les uns et les autres beaucoup
d'homosexuels même se sont sentis très
gêné pendant ce débat et
connexion pour mes doutes qui sont
contre cc mais quand vous étiez un
aplomb tourner pour les gros dixièmes
après tout je respecte la parole de ceux
qui sont contents quand vous disais je
suis plutôt courte mais je respecte la
parole de ce que sont pour vous faisiez
étriper en place publique croit pas que
ça mérite un peu mieux que simplement tu
es courroux contre les homos étaient
pour ou contre le mariage a mérité d'un
putsch ines c'est la phrase de georges
bush et avec l'irak il disait si on est
pas avec moi c'est vous êtes pour moi ça
reste des phrases c'est une vision
historique et fait une vision une
conception de la société qui n'est pas
celle des centristes c'est pour ça que
je suis là où je suis d'ailleurs parce
que ça je ne suis pas je pense pas que
parce qu'on n'est pas avec moi on est
contre moi mais j'ai espoir qu'on
devienne abriel versant politique mais
j'ai espoir aussi qu'on pourrait
converger tous les deux et que je
pouvais faire un pas vers le tronc et
c'est pas vous disiez tout à l'heure
naïveté je crois en elle non j'ai pas de
projet pas prêt malin mais je trouvais
pas le mot ne vous inquiétez pas non
mais je comprends ce que pour on peut
dire aux gens bah oui le monde
ils sont gentils c'est les bisounours
sont sympas alors ça c'est encore pire
mais non je crois qu'il ya un besoin va
vous que je ne connais pas de société
qui fonctionne si vous faites pas
l'aider pas les uns vers les autres
sinon vous mettez en tension et ça
explose et ça explose dans le temps l'on
s'expose pas demain matin
d'ailleurs je pense parce que j'y passe
quand on connaît françois bayrou c'est
tout sauf un bisounours il a des
positions fermes seraient ils des
solutions devraient faire des fermes sur
certains ont pu voir un sujet contre ce
que pouvaient être ses intérêts quand
ils se lèvent contre la privatisation
des autoroutes en 2005 il était seul il
était 2 pour être très juste il y avait
charles de courson si les députés et des
langages qu'ils étaient 2 mai ils
étaient pop de la marne et on n'a pas
beaucoup entendu évidemment les
socialistes parce qu'on dise oui peu
après et on apparaît évidemment entendu
la droite à cette époque là donc voilà
aujourd'hui la privatisation des
autoroutes je peux combien ça
rapporterait ce serait exactement la
taxe qu'on n'a pas réussi à mettre en
place sur les poids lourds
on va pas honte on va pas entendre des
partis dit de l'establishment peuvent
tellement de postes peut-être à se
répartir
ça c'est un autre sujet un autre sujet
merci encore merci à main levée une
conversation passionnante vous êtes le
numéro deux du modem donc faux
secrétaire général du modem de françois
bayrou on va continuer de vous suivre
suivre votre actualité
et je rappelle donc tout le modem
présente à nantes
al marri 1 bouteille thierry malara donc
sur le canton de nantes six sur le
canton de guérande catherine bailhache
et xavier brucker et sur le canton de
saint nazaire de dominique trigodet et
jean michel texier
merci marc fesneau darcis fait le
déplacement
merci avec plaisir